STORIES TO TELL.
>> Tucker: A HUGE STORY, IF
YOU REMEMBER.
NBC SAID IT WOULD FIX ITSELF,
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT AND
PREVENT IT FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN.
WE HAVE A FILMMAKER AND
NETWORK NEWS ANCHOR INCLUDING
HERE AND FULL PAGE AD THAT
WILL RUN TOMORROW MORNING AND
A PIECE ON THE FOX NEWS.com
OPINION SECTION.
PUBLISHED MINUTES AGO WHICH IS
WORTH READING.
LINDA, THANK YOU FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: ONE REASON I'M
GRATEFUL YOU ARE BRINGING THIS
TO THE PUBLIC ATTENTION IS
THERE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
PUBLIC INVESTIGATION FROM
WHICH WE COULD LEARN WHAT
HAPPENED.
WHERE IS IT?
>> THEY PUBLISHED RESULTS OF
THE SO-CALLED INVESTIGATION
BUT THE TRUTH WASN'T IN THERE.
BECAUSE AT LEAST SIX WOMEN, AT
LEAST SIX WOMEN VICTIMIZED BY
MATT LAUER ACCORDING TO THEM
TELLING ME PERSONALLY OR
PEOPLE CLOSE TO THEM TELLING
ME PERSONALLY WERE NEVER
INTERVIEWED.
THEY HAD DAMAGED DETAILS ABOUT
LAUER AND OTHERS IN MANAGEMENT
WHO ALLEGEDLY PROTECTED HIM.
NOTHING HAPPENED.
THEY WEREN'T SPOKEN TO PROPER
LY.
THERE ARE FOUR MEMBERS ON-AIR
TALENT WHO WORKED CLOSELY WITH
MATT WHO WERE NEVER
INTERVIEWED.
THEY TOO HAD IMPORTANT
INFORMATION AND I BELIEVE THE
NETWORK KNEW IT.
NOT ONLY IMPLICATED MATT BUT
IMPLICATED OTHER MEN IN
POSITIONS OF POWER AT NBC
NEWS.
THAT NEVER GOT INVESTIGATED.
THERE HAS TO BE A QUESTION OF
WHY?
IS IT BECAUSE HE, HIMSELF HAS
A HISTORY OF REPORTED SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT IN THE WORKPLACE IN
THE PAST?
SO HE, HIMSELF, IS GUILTY?
OR IS IT BECAUSE HE WANTED TO
PROTEST OTHER HIGH PROFILE MEN
AT THE COMPANY?
HE CARES MORE ABOUT THE BOTTOM
LINE AND DOESN'T REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE WOMEN WHOSE LIVES,
CAREERS AND REPUTATIONS ARE
BEING DESTROYED.
HE JUST CARES ABOUT THE MONEY
AND THE MAN HE WANTS TO
PROTECT.
>> Tucker: NBC IS PART OF A
LARGER PUBLIC COMPANY COMCAST.
YOU WOULD THINK THEY HAD AN
INTEREST TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THIS.
WHY HAVEN'T THEY?
>> THIS IS LONG OVERDUE THE
COMCAST BOARD OF DIRECTORS GET
INVOLVED.
THEY ARE DIRECTORS OF A
PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANY.
THEY ANSWERABLE TO
SHAREHOLDERS AND THE PUBLIC.
THIS IS A BROADCASTER THAT IS
REGULATED BY THE F.T.C.
SO THESE BOARD OF DIRECTORS,
THEY CANNOT GET AWAY WITH
BURYING THEIR HEADS IN THE
SAND.
THESE ARE REAL WOMEN WHOSE
LIVES AND CAREER AND
REPUTATIONS ARE DESTROYED.
THEY CAN'T IGNORE THEM.
COMCAST JUST PUT OUT A TWIDDLE
HANDLE YESTERDAY THAT SAYS,
"COMCAST CARES."
DOES IT REALLY?
THE DIRECTORS NEED TO MAKE IT
THEIR BUSINESS TO GET INVOLVED
AND INVESTIGATE ALL OF THE
ALLEGE PREDATORS AT MBC
NEWS -- NBC NEWS, NOT JUST
MATT LAUER OR TOM BROKAW THAT
ASSAULTED AND HARASSED ME BUT
MANY OTHERS WHO NEED TO GET TO
BOTTOM OF IT AND CLEAN OUT
WHAT IS WRONG WITH NBC NEWS.
BE A BACON OF THE JOURNALISTIC
ORGANIZATION SHOULD BE.
>> Tucker: YOU MENTIONED
ANDY LOOK WHO RUNS THIS AND
SUGGESTED HE, HIMSELF, OUGHT
TO BE INVESTIGATED.
HAS HE BEEN?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK
THERE IS EVIDENCE HE SHOULD BE
SUBJECT OF AN INVESTIGATION?
>> I KNOW OF TWO VICTIMS WHO
HAVE BEEN INTERVIEWED BY
REPORTERS.
I KNOW OF A MEMBER OF CBS NEWS
MANAGEMENT WHO WAS INVOLVED IN
BOTH OF THE CASES WHO
CONFIRMED THAT TO ME.
SO, YES, THAT EXISTS.
IT'S ALSO BEEN IN PRINT.
THIS IS OUT IN THE NEWS.
WHAT IS SHOCKING TO ME IS THAT
THIS IS EASY FINDABLE.
YOU CAN GOOGLE THIS.
DOES NBC UNIVERSAL AND COMCAST
JUST NOT CARE?
DOES ANDY LOOK'S BOSS STEVE
BIRK KNOW ABOUT IT AND NOT
CARE HE HAD ALLEGED I WILL SAY
PREDATOR RUNNING THE NEWS
DIVISION?
DOES BRIAN ROBERTS NOT CARE?
COMCAST WAS FOUNDED AS A
FAMILY COMPANY.
TELL ME HOW THAT IS A FAMILY
COMPANY WHEN WOMEN ARE
ABUSESSED AND BEING SILENT?
NON-DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS AND
THE FORCED ARBITRATION ARE
LITERALLY CHOKING THE VOICES
OFF.
AND PREVENTING THEM FROM
SPEAKING.
HOW FAIR, MORAL AND ETHICAL IS
THAT?
THIS IS A NEWS ORGANIZATION.
THEY SHOULD DO MUCH BETTER.
>> Tucker: THE FACT THAT
ANDY LOOK HAS BEEN ACCUSED OF
THAT WHO IS RUNNING IT IS
SHOCKING.
CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF THE
TIME FRAME OF ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST ANDY LOOK -- ANDY
LACK?
>> THEY WERE IN THE '80s I'M
TOLD BY PEOPLE WHO WERE
KNOWLEDGEABLE OF THIS AS AN
EXECUTIVE PRODUCER OAF WEST
57th.